and maintain a good Pawn structure yeah  you're right David many many games in  the database and uh I'm guessing now  that  the choice for white is still very much  there you know white can I actually step  back the queen if she's attacked and  still there is the option of perhaps  castling the king to the right or to the  left if you can get very ambitious  so in terms of chest style who do you  think this uh this position will favor I  think I'll favor Eric I've actually had  this position with black a few times  I've done very poorly from this position  yeah C5 is is standard queen E3 this has  been played many many times why does  effectively got a porn majority on